all right what's up everyone this time i
am recording at night so i'm gonna go to
bed right after this uh just did my
collaboration video with uh another
pretty prominent youtuber whose channel
is
about a thousand times the size of mine
so maybe we'll actually have a little
bit of a community here soon and i won't
have to do a day in the life video which
would be lit
um in the meantime i am going to be
making a video that i have been putting
off for literally months now just
because i wanted to do other stuff and
some guy asked me to probably make a
video about this maybe on episode five
and i've kind of just been a dick and
putting it off so i'm glad i could
finally get to it i'm gonna have to find
that original comment and tell him i did
this but um okay let's talk about uh
serialization
alrighty so what do i mean by data
well basically for starters on computers
most data is actually stored in memory
and we're going to be doing that through
the use of objects or classes or
something like that
but a lot of the times we have to go
ahead and transport this data somehow
and generally speaking we have to do
this as a byte stream that could be
either writing this data to a disk for
example or sending it over the network
to another computer in a distributed
system
either way the point is we have to
actually be able to convert data from
this in-memory representation which
might contain things like hashes or
pointers and go ahead and put that into
a format readable by other computers
there are a lot of ways to go about
doing this there are a lot of ways that
we can represent this data and each
obviously has their pros and cons and
we're going to discuss a bunch of those
in this episode
so as you can see for example if i
wanted to convert
the class below which is a person and
you know has some key features that are
extremely important
to a sequence of bytes
i would have to go ahead and convert
that pointer over somehow and be able to
kind of serialize that maybe as json or
something else but we'll discuss all
these options in a second
okay so what's the naive approach to
serialization well as it would turn out
most programming languages actually have
libraries built in in order to serialize
objects
there's pickle marshall serializable but
all of these are pretty bad in the sense
that
it pretty much limits you to one
language which is not huge they're not
very focused on performance which is
another issue with them
and additionally they offer kind of some
security vulnerability in the sense that
um if you know someone with malicious
intent can get you to kind of de-pickle
or de-marshal
some arbitrary byte stream that they
wrote it might allow them to instantiate
arbitrary classes and do things that you
don't want them doing
so as a result generally speaking these
language specific serialization
frameworks while easy to use are
probably not the move
okay what about standardized encodings
like json or xml well basically as you
can see there's a lot of red that i
wrote here but the truth in the matter
is
these are extremely popular and the
reason for that is that they're
extremely popular
you know it's kind of a network effect
which is that if you can get two
different companies to go ahead and
agree on some sort of common format for
data exchange
there's a ton of value in that and so
the fact that json xml are so widely
used in the past just encourages the you
know further use of them and especially
for cross-organizational data transfer
json and xml are both extremely popular
however they definitely have their
issues for starters with xml in
particular you can't really
differentiate between numbers and
strings for json you can't really
differentiate between integers and
floats and with floats in particular you
can't really specify the precision of
floats
additionally you can only deal with
unicode strings as opposed to binary
ones consisting of just zeros and ones
and then finally they're not
particularly compact which means there's
more network overhead to have to
actually go ahead and send some xml from
one computer to another same goes for
json main reason for this being that we
have all these you know strings
representing keys or fields that we have
to send over and that's kind of annoying
you can improve the size of your
encoding a little bit by binary encoding
however even still even with this slight
optimization you still have to go ahead
and include all of those field names and
so you're not actually doing that much
better
so instead what do a lot of companies
want to go ahead and use when they're
doing this kind of internal data
transfer only as in yeah you're
transferring data from computer to
computer but it's within your company so
you can kind of deal with you know
getting computers to agree on the format
that you're going to use
well this is where something like thrift
or protocol buffers comes in thrift and
protocol buffers are two libraries
created by facebook and google
respectively i think thrift has since
been open source to the apache license
but basically all they do is they create
these very compact binary encodings that
they're able to do so because before
actually going and creating the binary
encodings
what you do in thrift and protocol
buffers is actually specify a schema of
the type of message that you're going to
go ahead and encode so once this schema
is provided you can actually use code
generation tools in your ide to
represent classes for all of these types
of messages
and basically the way that they work is
that with these two in particular each
of these fields within a message
actually has a number
and that number is going to allow you to
very compactly kind of express which
field it is that you're sending in a
json message as opposed to having to
write out the entire name of a string
another thing that these are really
useful for is for documenting schema
evolution so basically if you're going
to have some sort of set schema for your
data it is probably the case that at one
point or another throughout the life
cycle of your application development
you're going to actually have to change
that data additionally even things like
rolling upgrades in your servers mean
that it's very likely that servers are
going to be running different versions
of software at the same time and as a
result we want to be able to achieve
both backwards compatibility and
forwards compatibility where backwards
compatibility basically just means that
newer code can read the messages encoded
by older code forwards compatibility is
basically just saying that older
versions of the code or older versions
of the software on the server can read
messages written by the newer code
it doesn't necessarily mean that they
have to be handled in the same way but
it does mean that you at least don't
want things crashing
so how does schema evolution work in
both protocol buffers and thrift well
for starters everything is kind of based
around those field tags right field tags
are what we use in order to identify
kind of which data corresponds to which
field
so as it turns out you actually can't
change existing field tags but you
definitely can add new ones and so in
addition to being able to kind of add
these new fields with unique tag numbers
we know that this both ensures forward
compatibility because the old code can
basically just ignore any new fields
included in messages and it also ensures
backwards compatibility because the new
code since it has still those existing
field tags from before it can actually
go ahead and read all these fields
contained in the old versions of the
messages
that being said
obviously any um kind of new field tags
that we're adding have to be optional
because otherwise those old messages
aren't going to contain them and it
would crash newer versions of the code
and then additionally depending on the
certain um you know situation that
you're dealing with you can sometimes
actually change the data type of the
code you can refer to the documentation
for these services um
for which data types you can change to
what
but that being said
protocol buffers and thrift are
certainly not perfect
by virtue of having to evolve your
schema by adding only new tags and not
actually kind of being able to add and
remove fields as you go we lose a lot of
flexibility because that doesn't really
reflect how actual database schemas
evolve right like it's the fact that a
lot of the times columns will just be
removed and so if you want to go ahead
and automate kind of this schema
generation for a given existing format
of data it's hard to do that because the
schema generation versus the actual data
formatting is not going to be one-to-one
if you just have to basically
add a field even though you know in
reality some columns may have been
removed from that database so i'll
explain that more in a little bit but
basically the solution to this is apache
avro
so similar to protocol buffers and
thrift in the sense that you know we're
using this to kind of encode these
different types of messages using a
schema
however it's better suited for cases
where you have big data and data where
the scheme can definitely change over
time
so again
we're declaring this schema but this
time there are no field tags so instead
we're using the schema to decode the
data but it's got to be in the same
order as the fields
and additionally we can still have
schema evolutions so how do we actually
have schema evolutions
well basically there's this concept of
the writer and the reader schema so
basically every message that's encoded
is encoded with a writer schema and then
eventually that message is going to
reach some endnote where it is going to
be decoded and the endnote contains some
sort of reader schema now it is the case
that the writer schema and the reader
schema can actually be different
and abro kind of has some cool logic to
actually go ahead and kind of rectify
the differences between them and it's
mainly through the use of the actual
field names themselves so as you can see
in the image below basically even though
the ordering of the field names is not
exactly the same
if you contain both the writer schema
and the reader schema you know when
trying to make a read or you know
deserializing a message you can go ahead
and say okay well now i see where the
username field should be now i see how
kind of interest maps to interest and
favorite number maps to favorite number
and so even though the order is changed
you can go ahead and rectify that and
kind of figure out which fields of the
message plug into which fields
so basically what we now do is if these
schemas are different if there are
fields present in the writer schema and
not in the reader schema means that we
no longer care about those they can just
be ignored if there are fields present
in the reader schema and not in the
writer schema then we have to go ahead
and use the default value provided for
those fields this is something that you
can obviously do in avro and it's
probably something that you should be
doing in order to go ahead and make sure
that your schema can evolve over time
hence obviously fields can only be added
or removed if they have a default value
because otherwise you're going to be in
trouble and it's not going to know what
to kind of make of a given field if it's
not included in the document
okay so how do we actually optimize
network bandwidth because i just kind of
mentioned that
you know
now with avro in order to kind of decode
a message you need both the writer
schema and the reader schema which is
problematic if we're sending all of
these messages over the network we don't
want to have to also include the writer
schema that can take up a ton of space
it'll slow everything down it's not
really acceptable but do keep in mind
that a lot of the time
what you're doing with avro is dealing
with hadoop files and what that means is
that you probably have one big file and
all of these records encoded in the same
way so generally speaking you can
actually just go ahead and send that
writer schema over one time and then use
that for all of those different records
that being said
if you have a bunch of records that are
written in all these different ways what
you can actually do is after encoding
them you can include a version number
with each record that corresponds to the
writer schema and then that way the
decoding uh you know the decoding node
can go ahead and pull the correct writer
schema
using the version number every single
time it's decoding a message and that
way you only have to you know send over
all of the versions of the writer's
schema once
okay so why are field tags bad because i
kind of touched upon this before and
this is kind of where avro
optimizes over both thrift and protocol
buffers
basically
the point is a lot of the time you want
to be able to automate the task of
having all of these different things in
a database and keep in mind that
database schema can be evolving over
time and then we want to be able to
automatically create that serious
serialization schema from the updated
database configuration we want it to all
be a very seamless process because if
we're ever going to do like an etl job
which basically means pull everything
from the database and plop it into
something like a distributed file system
it's very important to kind of be able
to automatically generate the
serialization if we had to do it
manually by hand every time that would
be really annoying
so basically
avro allows us to more easily automate
this process because like i said before
it doesn't rely on having to kind of
just append new fields with a unique
field tag but instead you basically just
list out whatever you have in there and
then the avro logic will kind of figure
out the differences between the reader
and writer schema
obviously if you do think about it and
you kind of are logical you probably can
automate the thrift or protocol buffers
process as well
however it just seems a little bit
easier to do it with avro
okay and then let's also just quickly
touch upon how schema evolution is
really useful in databases we have this
concept of data outliving code which
means that in a database we have records
that are potentially written
from multiple different versions of a
writer schema and we have servers that
are reading
rows from the database using potentially
many different
you know serialization schemas on read
so we have all these different schema
mismatches and as a result of that being
able to use this framework for
evolving data make sure that you have
this forwards and backwards
compatibility in order to make sure that
processes don't crash from data that was
eventually written to the database in
different formats
you also just have to make sure to keep
in mind that any time you're performing
a read modify update cycle with
an older version of the reader schema on
the basically the node that's going to
perform the update that you basically go
ahead and you know don't just like
ignore all of the data that isn't in
your reader schema because eventually
when you make that update you want to
make sure that data is still included
even if it wasn't important to you you
know in the actual code itself so that's
one thing to keep in mind
okay so in conclusion basically these
text serialization libraries are super
commonplace especially just within
services that only stay within one
organization right once you're going to
cross organizational services you
probably want to be using something like
json because of the super high support
but within one organization protocol
buffers thrift avro can all save you a
ton of network i o almost maybe even
half as much especially if you're
transporting terabytes of data over the
network and so these have shown to be
super useful not only for actually
saving time via this kind of binary
compression but in addition to that the
schemas act as effectively a
documentation of all the different types
of messages and the data evolution that
you have over all of your services and
that allows you to decode older messages
or even just you know take a look and
say like oh this is how we originally
had things that's how we changed it and
it's a really good form of documentation
in that sense
so overall i know this is kind of like a
topic that may not come up as much
during systems design interviews however
you know in practical considerations
being able to actually encode data
or serialize it into a byte stream more
efficiently is hugely important for
saving time especially when working with
big data in either batch or stream
processing
all right guys have a good one and i'm
gonna pass out